former President Obama hitting the
campaign trail last night here's some of
what the great person said when there is
a vacuum in our democracy what we don't
vote when we take our basic rights for
granted other voices fill the void and
demagogues get out there and they
promise simple fixes to complicated
problems this this is not normal what
we're seeing it is radical he also went
on to say people are stressed because of
the anger they see on TV which allows
quote opportunists to try to exploit
America's history of racial ethnic and
religious division Geraldo that's a mean
thing to say about MSNBC you know the I
was just think it was daydreaming when
you he was obviously about Trump Dana is
joining my wife and I for dinner and I
will Dana will see and Peter will see
how it is in my family
how one one-half of my family takes one
way the other takes and and this what
President Obama is doing is demonizing
even as he condemns the demonization
he's you know the the the language that
he uses and you know the the
condemnation that he wields is you know
he's doing the same thing that the
people that opposed him and and and read
the whole you know born in Africa it's
the same thing only more elegantly
wrapped than I limited and his people
have been saying that Donald Trump is
the one that's tearing down institutions
and traditions and decorum yet Barack
Obama has gone out and as a president a
post president destroyed that legacy in
that tradition of presidents not
speaking out after the other guy is
least had two to three to four years now
he was asked this question as he was
leaving office and he was asked how are
you gonna handle your post presidency
and he said quote I want to be
respectful of the office and give the
president-elect Trump an opportunity to
put forward his platform in his
arguments without someone popping off
now he is popping off right here and
these are not statesmen like speeches
these are not you know you get paid
half a million dollars to speak in China
or something like that to a corporate
group these are red meat rallies in
swing districts Ohio Ohio Accord raised
right in fact dairy it's not treating
him the way they would treat a
Republican president could you imagine
Trump after eight years and he's done
and then like the next midterm broken
the seal yeah definitely broke the seal
here watch presidential seal language I
think its language breaking the seal
anyway let's get back to some language
here Obama is using words like
opportunist none of this is normal
demagogues you know promising simple
fixes to very difficult problems he did
all of that saying that this president
is threatening democratic institutions
ok fine but make a better argument about
exactly why because I'm pretty sure it
was Barack Obama he used the Justice
Department to not only go after
reporters but to go after small
businesses and gun owners who tried to
sell things and they would go after the
banks to pressure them the IRS the epa
going after small farmers that sort of
thing so if you want to talk about norms
and have a real argument about these
things
barack obama doesn't really have a
strong pudding to stand on and paved the
way for plenty of things that were not
normal during the presidency Danny does
this motivate people or get motive well
it depends so I think that it would have
been very useful for perhaps even
Michelle Obama to say to the Democratic
Party Barack Obama is not coming to save
you okay so he is now a post president
you're gonna have to raise the money on
your own or you know he could do a
little bit but you are you got to find
your next leader because he is going to
be opposed you're wishing that she said
that I'm saying that she yes well I
think it probably have been better for
Democrats in the long run because if
he's going to be out on the campaign
trail between now and November you know
what happens on November 10th which is
the day after the election you're on the
road to 2020 so if he's getting all of
the attention where can the new
Democratic leadership try to emerge he's
taking up all the time my sense was and
I thought that you know I cry when he
was elected it was like the fulfillment
of my my adolescent dream to see him a
black man becomes
the United States I was so overwhelmed I
cried like Oprah
but right like it doesn't seem to me
that he had much traction in terms of
the the Hillary Clinton campaign ticket
he doesn't do well for that seat so that
is my point is that he's won that's not
it's not necessarily going to work but
also if he's having to diminish his
post-presidency by doing this for
something that may not welcome party
Obama said okay you're not he's you're
not doing this and I'm going to tell
them you're doing you don't get to be
mad is that every time Obama talks the
obedient media describes him as fiery
it's a fiery speech if he ordered like
kale salad the baby will go Obama
fiercely orders kale salad a bold order
President Obama is fiery they say
president Trump is angry exactly before
it's like the subtle little fellow
insightful there's a theory that's going
around and I'm going to regurgitate it
like it's my own that's the reason he's
so desperate to go out and campaign for
the Democrats in the midterms is because
when the Democrats take the house if
they do they're going to shut down all
of the oversight and surveillance of all
of the FISA abuses that were going on in
his administration such good points
[Laughter]
Obama is back on the campaign trail but
when he ran in 2008 it was all about
hope and change and a positive message
but now he's just lecturing and the
issue for Democrats now is regaining
Democrats who voted for Trump yep afro
Obama to go out on the trail and accuse
them of bigotry and fear-mongering and
being opportunists like those are the
people who actually voted for you the
first time it was the one you accusing
them and lecturing him that is not going
to get them back to the Democrat and he
was the one that lost those white
working-class moderate Democrats that
have now left to go to Trump the last
night demographics anymore we got to go